hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes my name is Matt Simon I'm here
to recap the most ravishing language and
ideas from the last week of Wired first
step today we're talking about nick
words and underwires alt text column
last week Laura Schulberg that a roundup
of still elusive fake particles in light
of the discovery of the Higgs boson one
of these he dubs the macquarie this is
an interesting construction adding mick
to the beginning of a noun interesting
unless of course you work in McDonald's
marketing department the idea is to take
the alleged dull mass production of
McDonald's and apply it to another now
so we have the job which is a monotonous
gig and we have the Nick world which is
a culturally sanitized planet run by
corporations you may be familiar with
this if you happen to be alive right now
the most widely used of these
pejoratives is McMansion these are the
quickly produced cookie cutter homes
that some might say lack taste you
should never however try to eat a
McMansion interestingly there's an
actual McDonald's McMansion on Long
Island it's a McDonald's in a mansion so
if you're a new hyde park in Long Island
and you decide you want to know exactly
what it's like for rich people to enjoy
McDonald's in the comfort of their own
palatial homes this is the place to be
now is as good a time as any to admit
that I had a fairly unhealthy obsession
with the Ghostbusters when I was a kid
my awesome father went so far as to
hand-paint the Ghostbusters logo on my
wall so I was pumped up last week when
gadget lab included proton packs and
it's gallery of awesome things to
strapped to your back I want to talk
specifically about the articles mention
of ectoplasm many folks think that the
idea of goo of behind by ghosts was made
up for the film when in fact the idea of
ectoplasm has been around since the
Victorian era this is when séances were
all the rage mostly because people
didn't have the Internet to tell them
how goofy and unscientific they were
being and the seance a medium would
gather people up in a room and start
contacting
but since it's hard to prove that it
goes whispered to you something about it
being too hot outside whatever it is
goes get angry about the mediums
introduce the idea of ectoplasm are they
sort of tangible manifestation of the
spirit so where did this ectoplasm come
from it came from the mediums mouths of
course they would swallow fabric such as
muslin and then when the time was
sufficiently dramatic regurgitated and
voila you're now in contact with the
spirit realm conveniently enough the
mediums could only do this when it was
dimly lit in the room I know weird all
of this of course brings to mind the
seance room in Disneyland haunted
mansion where a disembodied head conjure
spirits this type of house has been
produced thousands of times across
America and haunted McMansion
subdivisions these homes are both
spacious and spiritually fulfilling
you